>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> I'm so delighted that
Michele Troy is able to be here.
She earned a BA in philosophy
from Boston College and went
on to earn an MA in English as
well there and received a PhD
from Loyola University in Chicago.
She has worked for many years
in the field of modernist.
She's currently a professor,
English, at Hillyer College,
University of Hartford, where
she also directs the honors
program there.
Today she will be speaking about a
subject that dovetails and is drawn
from actually her current book
that just came out from --
a little bit ago --
sorry about this.
Strange Bird: The Albatross
Press and the Third Reich.
It was published by Yale
University Press of this year.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Michele Troy: Okay, thank you all
so much for being here and thanks
to Sabrina and Eleanor
for inviting me to come.
Thanks also to the Library
of Congress for engineering
that fire drill that made my
afternoon a little spicier
and made me decide my talk was
in fact ready to go as it was.
So you're going to get what I have.
So basically I'm here to
talk about a publishing house
that few people beyond book
collectors, a couple of scholars,
and some, you know, print
culture studies aficionados
like yourselves know about.
Most people don't.
So in one sense we can imagine
I think that we're digging
up a piece of lost history.
So, you know, it's like on those
TV shows where someone holds
up an artifact and tells
you the story behind it.
So this is our artifact
for the moment,
It's a Brave New World
by Aldous Huxley.
You'll know the novel, of course.
But this version was printed in
Nazi Germany in English in 1933,
again in 1935, and
then again in 1938.
So the hidden story of
Albatross behind a volume
like this involves a lot
of different threads.
I mean, British American
books in the Third Reich.
We have censorship.
We have propaganda.
We have books in wartime.
Also the paperback revolution.
But there's also something
else that you
as print culture studies people
may find fascinating that I also do
after all these years which is
that it was both a true innovator
in the paperback revolution
and it was also a really
interesting political player
in a very fraught political
time in Europe.
In fact, its design,
the way that I see it,
was really integral to
its political agenda.
And by the end of my talk, you'll
understand what I mean by that.
I'm going to start with a
broad sketch of Albatross,
for those who may not
be as familiar with it.
I'm going to talk a little bit
about the sleuthing process I had
to do in various archives.
And from there we'll move
to the strange entanglement
between Albatross and
Hitler's Germany,
and also its relevance
actually within the history
of print culture studies.
So I hope as I go on, you'll
understand why I chose
as my title Strange Bird: The
Albatross Press and the Third Reich.
Albatross was really a strange bird.
It was a complete cultural
outsider to the Third Reich.
But it became more and more
of an economic insider.
And so it was this position riding
the line that makes Albatross sort
of useful to Nazi authorities
but also really suspect as well.
And they manipulate that, Albatross
does, to their own advantage.
Okay, so moving forward.
For me the story of Albatross begins
here at the French National Library.
Erica and I were talking
about this in line.
In the reading room, I was
sitting there doing research
on something entirely different --
which is one of these ways
that research happens, right?
I was tracking the reception
of DH Lawrence in Europe.
I had done reception history
of various other Anglo
American authors as well.
And so I called up this book, the
Albatross Book of Short Stories,
which has a lovely silvery sheen.
And I was struck by the sense
that this book was very
strange automatically.
One, I had never heard of it.
Although I'd been studying
the reception
of Anglo American authors
in Europe for years.
It was a book in English, yet it
was published in 1935 Germany.
So already, you know, two
years after the book burnings,
to have some of these names on
the cover is pretty extraordinary.
Louis Golding, for
example, is a Jewish author.
Aldous Huxley has an
obviously very dystopian vision
and was very critical,
overtly critical,
of the Nazi regime in his essays.
DH Lawrence was very controversial.
I mean, it's not exactly the
Nazi's top list of desired authors.
And after a little more
digging, it just got stranger.
So I found that Albatross had its
official headquarters in Hamburg,
Germany, and its editorial
office in Paris.
Yet, it was in fact largely
funded by British-Jewish interests
in London -- back in England, right.
So what happens is that it
was founded in November 1931,
just a little over a year
before Hitler comes to power.
And by March 1932, the
series has launched.
These are the first six titles.
And this was an ad designed for
the German book trade newsletter,
so there's German sprinkled
between --
German descriptions sprinkled
between the English
language titles there.
So as some of you may know,
Albatross was forged explicitly
to wrest control of the
continental market in English books
from Tauchnitz, which
was a German firm.
Bernard von Tauchnitz, in
1841, hatched this great idea
that he would print
English language books
and that would give
British publishers
and authors copyright
protection on the continent.
And so Tauchnitz was the
only name in town in fact
for accessible English
language books
that people could actually
afford at the time.
But Albatross leaders knew
that demand for modern books
in English had escalated over
the '20s and into the beginning
of the '30s, and they
wanted in on this game.
I also discovered over time
that two of the three leaders
of Albatross were in fact Jewish or
considered Jewish by Nazi standards.
So Kurt Enoch on the right,
who eventually became one
of the cofounders of the New
American Library, he was Jewish.
And on the left here, the director,
John Holroyd-Reece,
his father was Jewish.
So he was considered -- basically
I've seen uda [phonetic] next
to his name a number of
times in Nazi documents.
So there was also Nazi officials
repeatedly referred to Albatross
as a notorious foreign
firm with, you know,
operating in Jewish circles.
I mean, this language is very
strong in some of the documents.
And so yet, despite that,
I mean, despite the fact
that there's no love lost
between Albatross and the Nazis,
they publish roughly 450 books.
These are reprints of books
that have appeared elsewhere,
between 1932 and 1939.
So it's very substantial, beginning
with James Joyce's Dubliners.
So modern cutting-edge books.
Ending with, The Way to be
Alive, by William Saroyan,
which was ironically the last book
before war started, with this title.
And again, if you look at the
list given to German booksellers
in March 1933, it reads like a
Who's Who of modern literature.
Many of these people
are still taught.
And you have on here also
James Joyce's Ulysses.
And you have Lady Chatterley's
Lover.
So at this point I
was entirely hooked,
because I had just pieced together
enough to forge the questions
without really knowing the answers.
So, you know, why would the
Nazi regime tolerate this firm
when it had put so much
weight and so many resources
into crushing foreign influence?
And especially Jewish influence.
And equally as mysterious,
why would a cosmopolitan firm
with British-Jewish funding
tolerate Nazi Germany?
What's going on here?
So if you're feeling a little
like this at this point,
you're feeling like
I was at the time.
And it really I got attached
to this historical mystery
and went in search of it.
Over about 10 years, off
and on, in between teaching
and raising children,
you know, 30 archives
or so in about six
different countries.
So it wasn't as easy as I
thought it would be because --
well, for various reasons.
One is that there were not very
many articles written about it.
There were a couple of scholars
whose names who I might can talk
with you about later who had --
one in Germany and one in
Scotland who had done some work.
There was no central archive.
The Leipzig office
had been destroyed
in Allied bombing raids
in December '43.
The Reich Literary Chamber, which
supervised all the publishing
under the Nazis, their
publishing archives
of all the different publishers had
been destroyed in that same raid.
So the Paris and London offices
had been vacated after the war.
In fact, the London
office was also bombed.
So this massive archive which really
should've been a treasure trove,
the Reich Literary Chamber, when you
looked at the time in the catalog
of the German national archives,
there were four entries,
and these were these tiny little
files with almost no information.
And you know that a firm like this,
they had to have piles
of documents on them.
So to top it all off, I have to say,
my first research trip, I, you know,
showed up in Berlin, thinking,
okay, that's the central place.
And then I realized, oh, right, the
Nazi's organized things regionally.
So I had to go to Leipzig.
So I called Leipzig saying, I'd
love to hop a train and come
down there and look at files.
And the German archivist
was a little bit like, well,
who do you think you are,
some like American powerhouse?
And storm in and, you know,
expect files like that?
And I said, you know, no, no, I mean
tomorrow, you know, not right away.
But anyway, I think
he thought I was sort
of like this wonder
powerful woman, I don't know.
But anyway, my breakthrough
came when I did what any poor,
frustrated American
powerful researcher would do
when she doesn't have any
sources, and I went to a mentor,
whom some of you may know.
Do you know this guy, anyone?
[inaudible] On the
Wire, exactly right.
And what is Lester
Freeman always saying?
He's saying, follow the money.
You got to follow the money.
So I followed the money.
And, in fact, I had
assumed that I should focus
on the cultural agencies
in Nazi Germany.
But, in fact, it was only when
I started to follow the money
that the bigger picture
came to light.
Three are multiple examples of this,
but my first big breakthrough
happened not too far from here
in a seedy hotel near the
College Park National Archives,
when I realized, of course, as
a foreign firm during the war,
they would've had to be overseen
by the Reichskommissar
for enemy property.
So I read through all the entries.
And what happens is, you know,
I find British and French assets
but there are no names of firms.
Those are in fact in a
handwritten catalog in Germany.
So the archivist sends back to me
the news 800 pages of documents.
It's magic.
Such a treasure trove.
So that's really how I started to
get a breakthrough on this subject.
And it's documents like these,
which may seem very boring
and I know it's quiet blurry,
but this is just a list
of different bureaus or
chambers that were kept
in the know about Albatross.
And on this list, for example,
is the Reich Literary Chamber,
the Economics Ministry, the
Finance Ministry, the secret police,
the German Foreign Office.
I had never thought of looking at
the German Foreign Office before,
and yet it was really valuable.
And so I'm looking also
at Albatross's German
and French partners, at their bank
accounts, at Reich bank files,
German book trade association files.
And I mention all this because
I think when you're working
in print culture, or you're
working in publishing history,
it's kind of interesting to realize
the most obvious places we might go,
the literary archives,
the publishing archives,
aren't necessarily
always the only ones.
And it's important at
times to, you know,
look at those regulatory
bodies who set the parameters.
So this is the back story in a way.
And I'm going to move on now to
the first big most obvious question
of why the Nazis tolerated
this firm.
In fact, Albatross leaders
were worried at first
that their books wouldn't
be tolerated.
So there's the first official
boycott of Jewish businesses
that is scheduled for
the 1st of April, 1933.
And on the eve of that, you
have Max Christian Wegner,
who's here on the left, come
to visit Kurt Enoch in Hamburg.
And Wegner has been
at the Paris office.
And so he flies back
in or takes the train.
And they have a conversation.
They're thinking about moving, you
know, pulling stakes out of Germany.
They're thinking about moving
the warehouse to Switzerland.
They're thinking -- you
know, Wegner, as an Aryan,
could potentially purchase
Enoch's firm.
He was, you know, Jewish.
So they're thinking
about all these things.
And over time, things
just settle down.
And in fact, what's really
weird about this story is
that the Nazi authorities, in fact,
grant Albatross more leeway both
in terms of the content of
their books and in terms
of the foreign currency that they
allot them in order to take care
of their foreign expenses than they
do other German firms publishing
in German for a domestic
German audience.
So this is weird.
And when German publishers
start to figure this out,
they're also rather irritated,
certain of them, about that.
But the most important reason that
the Nazis tolerated Albatross is,
as I say in my book, that they
found Albatross's presence
in Germany less culturally
troublesome and economically useful.
So it's, again, about money.
Because Albatross was registered
in the German Registry of Commerce,
because the books were
produced in Leipzig,
they count as German products
in the international trade balance
even though they were published
in English, it doesn't
really matter.
This meant that every book sold
abroad gives the regime foreign
currency, which, of course,
they desperately needed
because they were trying to rearm.
In essence, the Reich
Literary Chamber was told
to give Albatross a pass.
And this is a quote from a Reich
literary official to a German reader
who complained about a
volume by Louis Golding.
In order to stay competitive
against non-German firms abroad,
Albatross is forced to publish
books that in terms of their content
and in view of their authors
cannot always be endorsed
for German readers.
In general, the Albatross-Verlag
has hitherto occasioned
to no objections regarding
the distribution
of such books in Germany.
So in this way I think
Albatross's survival
under the Nazis challenges a lot
of assumptions we might
make about censorship.
I would have assumed -- I mean,
I could see no use for Albatross
from the beginning when I
started the research except
that the Nazis would
sensor their books.
And yet, they're really
allowed and in a way encouraged.
So here, you know, censorship
is not a moral issue.
It's an economic issue.
They are deciding to -- the
Nazis are willing to let go
of their own ideology in order
to get the foreign currency.
And this is not necessarily
astonishing,
but it's an interesting way to think
about how financial
factors swayed censorship.
And another piece of
this economic calculation
which is quite interesting is that
by this point in time, by 1934,
Albatross has taken over
the management of Tauchnitz.
So they used to started
off competitors and end
up on the same masta
[phonetic], as you can see here.
This is a brochure from 1935.
Albatross wanted to buy Tauchnitz
outright, it was not allowed to.
The Reich Literary Chamber
wouldn't allow it on grounds
that the firm was foreign.
It didn't say Jewish, but
that's probably implied.
So there ended up being a
strange three-way relationship,
that I can talk about later
if anyone's interested,
between the printer who
printed the two series --
the Tauchnitz Albatross series --
and Albatross and Tauchnitz
themselves.
So what happens, in essence, is
that if the Nazi regime wants
to get foreign currency
for Tauchnitz,
it has to keep Albatross
alive at this point.
Because the printer
who prints the book
and is technically the owner
doesn't know what to do,
how to market a series or
develop it, they're printers.
So it's a strange thing.
And, you know, as I
mentioned before, you know,
the Germans need foreign currency,
and books, as you can see here,
are the third largest export.
This is from a document by
the Reich Literary Chamber.
Okay, so at this point
I'm switching gears.
We have to do a little pivot to
ask the flip side of the question,
which is, why does Albatross
actually stay in Germany?
They have so many international
connections, they could just pull
up stakes and run their
series from elsewhere.
Were they just collaborating?
I mean, I did wonder
that for a while.
But I soon discovered the Albatross
leaders had their own agendas
at stake.
And here's the moment where --
it's an interesting print
culture moment I think,
that we can see exactly
how Albatross's design --
which was created by a German master
typographer, Hans Mardersteig.
How this design actually
helped advance Albatross's
political agendas.
So to get at these agendas, we need
to take a little trip to Paris.
We're going to go to
the Ile De La Cite.
And we're going to go right north
of the Notre Dame Cathedral.
There's a house that
looks like this.
It's 12 Roush.
And here's the beautiful door.
And you go through the door to the
inner courtyard, and then you can go
on into the Albatross office,
where you see John Holroyd-Reece,
the director, at work, with
one of his right-hand --
some of his right-hand
men and women there.
And so basically, Holroyd-Reece
took the position --
he played with Albatross's national
and international affiliations
quite liberally.
So he insisted, for example, in
Germany, that Albatross was German,
to benefit and get perks
from the German government.
And in England, of course,
Albatross was wholly British
and serves British interests.
And he -- this contention
becomes increasingly important
because as the atrocities are
continuing in Nazi Germany,
there's a question about
why is this firm continuing
to have ties and do business, right.
So he always claimed
that -- publicly --
that Albatross had decided to print
and sells its books in Germany
because that was the largest
English-speaking market.
It was worth about a third
of the continental market.
And I have Tauchnitz figures
that substantiate that also,
before Albatross took
over the management.
So he used the financial or
sales argument to say, okay,
we're keeping our books
in there for this reason.
And this is true as far as it goes.
Yet, I would say that
Holroyd-Reece often told a part
of the truth rather
than the whole truth.
He wasn't just the charming
British chap he seems.
In fact, he was born under
the name of Johan Herman Reece
to a German Jewish father
and a British mother
at an artist colony outside Munich.
When his father died in 1909,
his mother sent him to England
to Repton, the boarding school.
And he became so much an
Englishman in his manner
that he actually fought for
the British in World War I,
without his superior officer even
knowing that he was German born.
And I found out this
in his application
for British citizenship
after the war.
So if this were fiction,
Holroyd-Reece would
really be the perfect spy.
And in fact, one diplomatic
source early in the '30s,
claimed that Holroyd-Reece
had worked
for the British during World War I,
while he was still
a German national.
I will say in 1937, when French
intelligence services heard
Holroyd-Reece describing one
of his many publishing ventures
as a cover -- I'm not interested
in that, it's just a cover.
You know, they said,
well, a cover for what?
And they went and talked to him, and
I've seen the French files on this.
And he claimed to be working
for British intelligence.
So this adds another
little wrinkle to the story.
He did speak four languages
at least fluently.
He also worked as a Lloyd's broker
in England and had businesses
in France, which allowed him
to shift money pretty easily
across national lines.
Among other things, he
brokered a deal for heavy metals
for British investors in the
late 1930s, just before the war.
So he's got a lot of
things going on here.
I will also say one funny
little story about him.
And these are some
of the kinds of --
this story didn't actually
make it into the book,
so it's a bonus feature for today.
During the war, first world war, he
boarded part time with at the home
of one of his school chums.
And during this time -- he was
later accused in a divorce suit
of having an affair with the mother.
So according to the
Times, he denied the claim,
saying the mother was
lonely and friendless
and was getting no
answers to her husband.
And so he would go up to the nursery
to comfort her sometimes,
this was the story.
So sometimes, he said, he sat on
the bed and got under the eiderdown,
but he never got into
bed with Mrs. Wakley.
So you have this part
of the testimony --
this is just by way of showing you
the character running this firm,
the character behind it.
This is part of the
testimony from the judge.
Did you happen to kiss her
when you were lying beside her
under an eiderdown quilt?
I may have done so.
You need not further cross-examine.
Has a fine slapped
on him immediately.
So he's quite a character.
And you'll understand with this
little personal anecdote included,
that, you know, while
Albatross, like any publisher,
wanted to sell books,
this guys always had
at least one other agenda going.
He's got a lot of irons in the fire.
Now, one of Albatross's -- Albatross
didn't just want to sell books.
Tauchnitz wanted to sell books too.
And they can see that
their main clientele
as British and American tourists.
Albatross does something
different, and this is one
of its big innovations
in the market.
They decide they want to
reach out to native Europeans
who do not have English
as their first language.
So, for example, here's EM
Forster's A Passage to India.
At the bottom you can faintly
see Hamburg, Paris, Bologna.
The covers are very cosmopolitan.
Also, they included an explanation
of the color system
in four languages.
And also -- and I'll talk
about that in a moment.
But this is to appeal
to European readers.
If you don't know much about
these books but you want a mystery
for the train, you know
you should grab Red.
So it makes it easier for foreign
readers to actually land on a book
that they might like, right.
And I'll go through the
genres in just a minute.
They also had summaries in
three different languages:
so English, French, and German.
So again, a lot of foreign
booksellers didn't speak English.
So then they could look
at the summary on the back
and say, oh, here's so and so.
Oh, you tend to like love stories.
Well, here you go, this one
would be lovely for you.
So I want to say too, it's
partly the sheer beauty
of the Albatross design that
helps it nudge Tauchnitz
out of the market.
And you can see this, you know.
Tauchnitz was an innovator
in a particular kind of way.
Albatross invaded that market, it
was an innovator in another way.
But you know, different
genres, different colors.
So murder mysteries are red.
A love story is blue.
Satire or short stories are orange.
Writings of foreign
places are green.
Biographies are purple or kind
of a violet-magenta color.
Yellow is for psychological
novels, such as Woolston.
By the way, the psychological
ones are always the easiest
to find in these book stores.
The reds are hard to find,
those mystery novels.
I think they got read and reread.
Which is sort of funny.
Albatross also created a
spinoff, the Odyssey Press,
just to publish Lady
Chatterley's Lover.
These are ads for them,
not the books themselves.
And Ulysses.
So I mean, why reach out to foreign
readers at this point in time
with these beautifully
designed books?
Why does the design matter?
Well, it's helping
to sell more books.
It helps -- in fact, it's
part of a bigger agenda.
The British want control
over the British
and American books on the continent.
And think about the time.
This is a world in which books and
especially foreign books are seen
as carriers of national ideology.
So the more you can sell of
your own books, the better.
Governments are stepping back and
considering in a more organized way
than before how can books
be used as propaganda.
So we have, for example,
Geoffrey Faber saying,
books are not mere merchandise.
Books are a nation
thinking out loud.
We have a version of this during the
second world war in the States too.
Books are weapons in
the war of ideas.
So, you know, Albatross in its
English language books are wittingly
or unwittingly in the thick of this
world, right, as it's developing.
And the Nazis were -- another thing
to understand is the Nazis
are obviously way in the lead
when it comes to using books
to serve state interests.
The British were miserably behind.
And they were very well aware by
1930 that they were very far behind
in promoting their
own culture abroad.
They promoted their
own machines abroad.
So you could -- they had ads for
airplanes and things like that.
But they blocked funding for
cultural propaganda across the '20s,
feeling rather arrogant that
they just didn't need it.
There was a small group
that thought they did,
but they couldn't convince
the others.
So you end up with Clifford Norton
who is the British foreign office
affiliate and wartime investor
to Switzerland, we may tell
foreigners about our airplanes
and our coal strikes but not
about our poets and painters.
We met export bacon but not Bacon.
I love that quote.
So, you know, you basically
have Britain has been resting
on its laurels.
And by 1934 though, the French and
German governments were estimated
to be spending over a million pounds
annually on cultural propaganda.
So you have to think -- so
by 1934, the people who are
in the foreign office managed
to convince the government
to fund a similar cultural
propaganda initiative.
It was the British Council.
But guess what its budget was?
I couldn't even believe this.
5000 pounds.
So a million pounds versus 5000.
So this meant that when you have
Holroyd-Reece sitting in his office
in Paris -- which he
loved luxury, be the way,
as you can sort of see here.
Tapestries.
Medieval sculptures.
There are all kinds of
things he has in his house.
But when he helped to found
and fund Albatross in 1931,
he was inherently advancing the work
of the British Council
before it even existed.
So he founded Albatross
four years earlier
and with twice the startup funding
that he British Council had.
And that they're saying too,
Albatross fit to a T the goals
of Sir Reginald Leeper, who founded
the British Council in December --
the first head of the British
Council in December '34.
That it would be better for private
firms to promote British culture
so that it would come in under
the radar than it would be
for the government
officially to promote anything.
So with this idea, books
and propaganda in mind,
if you think about that, the
sales figure I said before,
roughly a third of
the market, is German.
That means your largest
English reading audience
in continental Europe
is Hitler's Germany.
And for the Nazis, they
just care about the 70
or 68% that's getting exported.
But for Holroyd-Reece to say
that there's 30% of the market
that still exists there,
is important.
And obviously as Germany annexes
more and more territory late
in the '30s, that number grows.
The reason that's important
is that --
and this help explain why
would Albatross stay put.
It's not about the money.
It's about their presence there.
In fact, Holroyd-Reece
was miserable with money.
They hardly ever made money.
It was about keeping
the books there.
And at this point in time, because
of German import restrictions,
it was very, very hard for
British publishers to get books
in if they wanted to
sell them in that market.
So in fact, the Albatross-Tauchnitz
operation becomes a huge boom
for the British Council.
So you have in November 1938, the
British Council's trying to figure,
should we start up some
libraries over there?
How can we get -- do we
do student exchanges?
What are we going to do to make sure
that Anglo-American culture
stays alive over there?
And in a report in November
1938, they say, again, cheapness
and excellence of Tauchnitz and
Albatross books place English
and American literature within
reach of any who are interested
and the most we could do would
be to present a small number
of carefully chosen
books to institutions
which are training younger people.
So they got this inside
track that's already --
you know, gives them an
advantage in this world
of cultural propaganda
at this particular time.
How did they gain that?
They gain it because of
their design and because
of their selection of authors.
In essence, Tauchnitz was
not producing modern authors
until the very last couple of
years before Albatross comes
into existence.
And so what happens is
Albatross also floods this market
with modern books that have
a lot more liberal ideas,
that would not have been able to
be easily accessible beforehand.
Okay, I want to come
back to this question
of lost history with
which I started.
And there's one print
culture piece I want to do
and then just two conclusions.
So I started off with this idea
that Albatross has largely
been erased from history.
And a lot of people
have asked me why.
How did a firm that was
once the largest purveyor
of English language books in
continental Europe in the 1930s,
just like just disappear, poof?
Where did it go?
So I can speak more
on this, you know,
afterwards if anyone's interested.
But there's a basic
combination of factors.
I mean, one is copyright
issues after the war.
One is that Albatross had
German ties before the war
and after the war.
That doesn't really suit -- you
know, it doesn't serve your interest
to have had German ties
that were too strong.
But I would also say it became --
Albatross became a victim
of the paperback revolution
that it helped to develop.
So the most obvious case is,
of course, Penguin books.
So when you see that little
Albatross on those books, you know,
people think Penguin, right.
And how many bookshelves have you
seen if you're book collectors
or lovers books, all the
different colors, right,
collected on the bookshelf
from the early Penguins.
So it's been long known
within book history
that Penguin took Albatross's model.
But what's really more interesting
even than that is that, in fact,
Allen Lane had signed a
memorandum of agreement to partner
with John Holroyd-Reece, the
Albatross director, in 1934.
And so what you have is
Holroyd-Reece realizing
that he can achieve
greater economies of scale
if he can include the
British market.
Because these books were not
allowed in the British market.
And so he teams up
with -- the idea is
that Allen Lane will print the books
in England and Lane will sell them
in England and Holroyd-Reece
will sell them on the continent.
So in the document it says, John
Holroyd-Reece will explain to,
you know, Lane's people,
the economies of scale,
how to get the most.
He was amazing with that.
He had Hans Mardersteig , the
guy who designed the covers --
he had him come up to Collins,
which was an Albatross partner
in Edinburgh, and show them
how they use a different font
so they could get more
words on the page.
But it would still look beautiful.
But this is the kind of thing
Holroyd-Reece was doing.
But in any case, so he shares
all of his economies of scale
with Lane, and what does Lane do?
We all know.
There's Penguin, the
next two, right.
So I think -- Penguin was just
the beginning, by the way.
We have Start Editions, which
is a group of British publishers
who get together to try to
get the continental market.
There's Zephyr out of --
Zephyr Books out of Sweden,
which emerges during the war
and when the Germans
forbid Tauchnitz books
from being exported anymore
and Albatross books then.
And here we have Kurt Enoch.
The story comes full circle.
Kurt Enoch, who was Albatross's
Jewish partner, lands in New York.
And during the war, works
for American Penguin.
I got this photo from his
first cousin once removed
who actually worked for
the IMF here in town
for years, just retired last year.
But essentially what happens
is, is Albatross can't hold
up against the competition anymore.
There are these -- you've
got Kurt Enoch coming back
with his New American Library books,
where they're so much
more cheaply produced.
They have access to the whole
American market, and they're selling
for a third to a quarter
of the price
that Albatross has
as its price point.
Albatross just goes under
after the war at that point.
Okay, and with that, just a couple
of points to leave you with.
The first has to do with something
I wasn't really able to address
in the talk today because
I was trying
to give it a print culture emphasis.
I've largely told you
a tale of institutions:
Albatross versus the Nazis.
However for me over the years,
probably one of the most compelling
things about the research I ended
up doing was -- and it's one
of the reasons I hope you'll
consider reading my book,
is that it's really also a
story of individual actors.
You have Kurt Enoch.
You have Max Christian Wegner.
And you have John Holroyd-Reece.
And all three of these
men are German-born men,
who chose against the odds
to found a multinational,
cosmopolitan publishing house,
really at the absolutely worst time.
So you have the ripple effects
of the American Great Depression.
You have European economies
foundering.
You have the rise of fascism.
And yet these guys persist.
And they're almost always, by the
way, in trouble with the Nazis,
for one reason or another.
But they sort of manage
to like wiggle around.
They find ways to get around.
They will pull the wool over the
Nazi's eyes with his emigration,
which is a story that's in the book.
But I think for me, I find
their attempts to maneuver
around the Nazi regime increasingly
meaningful, as we live right now
in a particular political
culture in our own moment.
And maybe it's really
appropriate to say this in DC.
But, you know, individual agency
seems to matter more than ever.
I think we need it more than ever.
And it's really important
we continue to believe
that what we do matters up against
these powers that be in extreme
of executive orders
that's threatening
to ruin whole pieces of our society.
So for me, actually this book
has a strange relevance now
that I never expected it
would have when I wrote it.
The second thing I'd like to leave
you with, and then I'm really done,
is this rather naught
question of collaboration.
It would be really
nice to say that, oh,
Albatross is inherently
subversive because its books were
in English, because they were there.
You can't really entirely say that.
I mean, I do think that they
had an important presence
and certainly British
propaganda agencies were happy
that they were there.
But in multiple artistic realms,
it was all for light entertainment.
Because it was seen as
distracting people from, you know,
the hardships of the day.
And so in a sense, if you include
Albatross in that entertainment
that was available to people,
you could say in a way, you know,
are they playing an instrument
in Google's orchestra
too in their own way.
You know, despite their good
intentions in this bigger context.
But I also think there's
this fact too.
That the more the Nazis cracked
down on Anglo-American books
and anything Anglo-American
in Europe during the years
of the occupation and the war,
the more that Albatross --
which is, by the way, largely
allowed during the war --
that they become one
of the last voices
for Anglo-American
culture in occupied Europe.
And it's my hope that through
the recovery of more documents
over time, that we'll actually
build a better understanding
of what these brightly bound
books meant to the readers
who accessed them under the
occupation and under fascism.
Thanks.
[ Applause ]
>> Take some questions?
>> Sure, yeah.
I'll just have a sip of
water and then we can go.
So.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Thank you so much for coming.
I know it's the beginning of
Columbus Day weekend also.
It's nice of you all to come out.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> I have tried really hard to
crack this Holroyd-Reece case,
British intelligence case.
I have a file number,
it's absolutely maddening.
Long story short, there's
someone who worked at Tauchnitz
who Holroyd-Reece mentored.
And that guy ends up a prisoner
of war in England after the war.
So I've had his file.
In that, there's a mention,
please send this document
over to so-and-so's who has
the John Holroyd-Reece file,
with a file number.
So I see that, and magic, okay, I
can do a Freedom of Information Act.
So I do that.
I put in two separate FIAs.
And I was told by the Brits
essentially something like,
we are sorry, we do not have
the requisite information.
So that's tricky.
I've looked at a ton of
foreign office documents.
I have not looked at the monitoring
service, which is far later.
Currently there's a huge
project to look at the Ministry
of Information documents in England.
And Simon Elliot is
the head of that.
I've written people within
that to try find out, hey,
have you ever come across
the name of Holroyd-Reece.
I have lots also of other
circumstantial evidence,
places he was -- he was in Germany
right before Hitler came to power.
He magically knows to leave France
the day of the invasion of Poland.
I mean, there are -- he's in France.
I know he's in France when the
French officials don't know he's
in France.
There are just a lot of
weird things about him
that don't entirely add up.
[inaudible] Well, Delmar,
it's interesting.
He knew Brendan Brackett,
who was the first head
of Ministry of Information.
So I presume he knew Delmar.
And in fact, this Tauchnitz
employee, who ends up a prisoner
of war, wanted to work for Delmar.
And was not allowed to because
the Brits didn't trust him.
But I've done -- I also contacted
the scholars who wrote the books,
the Official Histories MI Five
and MI Six, to ask them, you know,
a number of questions about, you
know, where do you suggest that I go
to look for this information.
And one of them said, look,
if you worked for MI Six
and had any ties there, it's a black
box, you're never going to find out.
You know, because they
don't out their people.
There's something -- if anyone
has ideas, send them to me.
Please email me, because I'm
happy to keep researching.
But August, maybe you'll have to
make that your personal project.
You can look up [inaudible].
We'll talk later.
And I'm sorry your name is Herschel?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
So there are some -- there's
Smaller I think is his last name.
I believe he used to
work for Penguin.
You know what?
I can look at the bibliography,
because there are a couple of things
in here that I would recommend.
Certainly Albatross was not
the first person to think
of doing paperbacks, right.
I mean, you have Reclam in Germany
and you have those little
yellow books that were out.
And you have plenty of cheap
books, paperbacks, in France also.
I think what Albatross does
differently is they're producing --
they're trying to give that
aura of really high quality.
A paperback is part of a collection.
It's part of a series,
an edited series.
This idea of the [inaudible] comes
from -- there's an editorial policy.
So I think that's where
they're trying
to make paperbacks
highbrow in a way.
But certainly they have
lots of precursors.
I'll show you, I'll look in there.
Hans Smaller is his name, I believe.
Yeah? What's your name?
Suzanne.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
I thought long and hard about that.
And the one thing is it's
not an exact replica.
The other thing is
that I have documents
from the Nazi files showing that --
because they were looking
into copyright
at the time for various reasons.
And The Bird itself was
copyrighted in Luxembourg
through this publishing holding
company that owned Albatross.
So Albatross had investors
behind it that --
so, in essence, this publishing
holding company went defunct.
And they were the holders
of the copyright.
So I had a document
that told me that.
So that's -- [inaudible] I
haven't had any repercussions, no.
And we're also hitting that
point too where I checked on --
for example, with James Joyce's
Ulysses, I was looking at that
as a precedent, but
the James Joyce --
International James Joyce Society
has regulations on copyright.
And in terms of the years when that
would have been designed and put
out there initially, it's
apparently no longer an issue.
Yeah?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
But that was one of the things
that Holroyd-Reece said actually
in an interview in
the postwar world.
He wanted to bring Albatross
back in the postwar world.
And he had these grand plans of
doing an international Albatross.
So Albatross would not only
do reprints in English,
but they would do translations
from English into other languages.
So stepping on a lot of toes,
right, of other publishers.
There are major copyright
issues there.
But what he said in an interview was
that he had chosen the name
Albatross because it carried
across languages and was
instantly recognizable as a word,
but also because -- exactly right --
it was the protected
sort of species.
[inaudible] the person who
comes up against the Albatross.
And in fact, it was
Albatross in the end obviously
that it took the final hit.
Susan, I do want to come back
to your question just briefly.
I mean, Yale was really
tight on copyright
for all kinds -- for everything.
So they I believe also
had their lawyers
or their people backcheck it.
I've never been so proofed on,
you know, every last quote,
everything had to have --
I had to have permissions
and show permissions
for every single thing.
Which is understandable.
[inaudible] Thank you.
I was really happy
they went with it.
I was really excited about
the design and I brought two
of the books down to try
to convince the editor
that he should consider it.
[inaudible] Well, I used
mystery genre color on purpose.
Although the research
is, you know, whatever,
it's standard scholarly
research at one level,
I tried to write it like a story.
It's a dense story
in parts, you know.
Because it's involving
looking at books.
And, you know, for example,
there's a chapter where a part
of Huxley's Beyond the
Mexique Bay was excised.
And I talk about, you
know, there's that too.
Most of the books that
did not happen with.
But that particular book, he called
Hitler the king of the new stupid,
so that wasn't really going to fly.
So there are chapters that deal
with things like that, you know,
that have a little -- I'm
a literary scholar too.
I'm a literary historian, as
well as a publishing historian.
But I tried to write it a little
like -- a little mystery in it.
So yeah.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
So now Tauchnitz already had
quite strong distribution.
In fact, in the Denuo munsha
[phonetic], which was a kind
of slightly intellectual journal
of the day, in the early '30s,
there was an ad saying, you
know, you can find Tauchnitz
on the smallest island
here to the, you know,
big urban centers and everything.
So Tauchnitz had ready
started in that zone.
But Kurt Enoch was the one who
worked promotion and distribution.
And they did expand
the number of outlets.
So they had -- in the '30s,
they had 6000 different outlets
across continental Europe where
you could buy these books.
Certainly railway stalls ready,
but they expanded the number.
And then another thing they
did was to go more heavily
into the school book market.
So Tauchnitz always
had a student series.
And the student series would
be often a portion of a book
and it would have questions and
it would have some translation.
It would have a glossary.
What Albatross did was sort
of take that idea but throw
out the structure and sort of say,
any of our books could
be school books, right.
And you can see this -- I don't have
it in this particular slideshow.
But I was doing some research in
Dutch this last year and they had
in the Dutch book trade
newsletter, there was an ad for --
just about school books, you
know, time to buy school books.
And then there's, you
know, Albatross
and Tauchnitz right
there, in 1934/1935.
So they're more radically -- and
this in fact is one of the things
that -- this is one of the things
that the Nazis liked
about Albatross.
Was that they kind
of envied those --
during the war, they wanted to use
those distribution networks in order
to develop their own series
in German but on that model
of the continental book in German.
You know, they want
that distribution.
There are a couple chapters
on that too in the book.
But the Nazis actually use
Albatross as a model, you know,
they co-oped them as it were.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Interesting.
They didn't have to worry -- you're
saying communist leaning authors or?
[inaudible] It's because
they're Anglo-American authors.
So they purchased their
rights from British publishers
and from America publishers
basically.
There were a couple of exceptions.
There's a famous Swedish
author, whose name I'm blanking
on right now, who wrote
the History of Capri.
>> Axel Munthe.
>> Yes, thank you.
So they had some Axel Munthe books.
But those were written
in English I believe.
>> Yes, they were.
>> And so that's seen
as sort of an exception.
I will say though, in
terms of like Steinbeck,
there's a Steinbeck story collection
right before the war starts.
And they excised a
story about a gathering
of communist leaning workers.
And they excised that
story from the volume.
So they were clearly,
you know, trying to do --
I don't want to portray the
Albatross leaders either
as these total radicals.
They don't want to get
into so much trouble
that they can't sell
the books there anymore.
But I was really surprised
that there was
so little problem with censorship.
The one book that really got
into the biggest trouble --
well, DH Lawrence's
Lady Chatterley's Lover
in English was suppressed not only
in German but also in English.
But also what's the book?
Gray Wolf by HG Armstrong, who wrote
-- what's the famous book he wrote?
Sorry, too many details in my
head today, I can't remember.
But he had been -- he wrote a book
essentially about the Turks --
and he'd been in World War
I but imprisoned in Turkey.
And so he basically had a lot of
dirt on Ataturk and was writing
about that liberally in
this particular book.
And the Germans -- it goes
out on the market in Germany
and then suddenly someone catches
wind of this, and they don't want --
the foreign ambassador
to Turkey is like we have
to have this book suppressed because
we don't want to alienate the Turks.
And so we want to keep them
as potential military allies.
We can't afford to let
this book out there.
But that's the one book, apart
from DH Lawrence's Lady Chatterley's
Lover, that I really saw
that there was some kind of action
taken against it in an overt way.
I mean, there are a
couple of other --
like Louis Golding's books end up
on the list of undesirable, harmful
and undesirable literature.
He's Jewish, so.
Anyway. Any other last questions?
You've been lovely as an audience.
It's just so fun to talk to people
who know a little bit
also about the background.
Thanks.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.GOV.